- Je m'y connais absolument pas
là-dedans, à qui parler,
où m'informer, qui appeler...
- Alex Carpentier fait parti
de ceux dont le vol a été
longuement retardé par Sunwing.
Ses probabilités de partir
vers le Sud fondent maintenant
comme neige au soleil.
ALEX CARPENTIER, voyageur
- Oui, c'est la première fois
que ça m'arrive.
- N'ayant jamais vécu
une telle situation,
il peine à s'y retrouver.
Mais depuis septembre dernier,
les voyageurs comme
Alex Carpentier sont mie
protégés par la loi canadienne.
Si un vol est annulé
ou sérieusement prolongé,
même si la situation est hors
du contrôle des transporteurs,
comme la météo,
"une réservation pour un vol
dans les 48 prochaines heures
doit être offerte."
Et si cela est impossible,
c'est un remboursement
l l les 30 jours
qui s'applique désormais.
ÉRIC BOISSONNEAULT, v.-p.,
Asso. des agents de voyage du Qc
- Votre vol était le 25 décembre
à 6 h le mati25252525 décembre,
ils l'ont remis à 7 h le soir.
Pour l'instant, aucun recours :
on doit attendre.
Le vol finalement du 25 décembre
à 7 h a pas lieu, reporté
au 26 décembre à 7 h le matin.
Là, vous avez le droit de
demander à la compagnie aérienne
un remboursementetetetet
sur votre vol.
- De l'autre côté de la
frontière, on sent les autorités
proactives suite au cafouillage
de Southwest Airlines et de
ses milliers de vols annulés.
Pour la Maison-Blanche,
la compagnie doit être tenue
responsable.
Aux États-Unis, les droits des
passagers sont rigoureusement
encadrés par une charte des
voyageurs. Un document qui
existe au Canada que depuis 2019
et qui pourrait aller plus loin.
MEHRAN EBRAHIMI, dir., Obs. int.
aéronaut. et aviation civ., UQAM
- Et là-bas, l'avantage, c'est
que le fardeau de la preuve,
c'est sur le dos des compagnies
aériennes, alors qu'ici,
chez nous, c'est les passagers.
x x x x x passagers de montrer
que la situation ne permettait
pas à la compagnie d'assurer
un vol. Aux États-Unis,
c'est l'inverse.
- En date du 20 décembre,
plus de 31 000 plaintes pour
annulation ou retard de vol
étaient en attente à l'Office
des transports du Canada.
Avec le chaos des derniers
jours, d'autres s'ajouteront
inévitablement, mais il est
cependant trop tôt pour
en connaître l'étendue.
Ici Aimée Lemieux,
Radio-Canada, Montréa